and you know this is crazy because you
know the most traditional wives don't
get their validation from me or any
external Source they get their
validation from their husband and that
really signals to me that something is
off where even at their age they don't
even know what men want men like young
hot chicks guys I don't know what to
tell you I'm not saying like I'm the
epitome of it but I'm saying like you
you look at Hollywood you know when
women watch a movie any any male movie
right when you think of like
Transformers who was in it Megan Fox and
it's so funny Margo Robbie what when she
was at her hottest she was in Wolf of
Wall Street who watches that men when
she kind of aged out she's in movies for
women she's in Barbie now because women
don't like to see women hotter than them
it's like this thing I don't know